Germs are like cars.
They are always on the move.
And our hands? They're
like one big freeway,
moving germs toll-free
from location to location
outside and inside your body.
But when you wash your hands,
you create a major roadblock,
stopping the germs in their tracks.
So, what would happen if you
gave up handwashing forever?
Your hands can have anywhere from 100,000
to a few million germs at any given time.
Some of those germs live naturally
on your skin to protect you,
but a lot of them are quite literally
picked up in the environment.
Those germs then sit,
waiting for transportation
to your mouth, nose, or eyes.
And these environmental
germs can be downright evil.
This was something we discovered
way back in the 1840s,
when Hungarian doctor
Ignaz Semmelweis noticed
that when doctors performed autopsies
and then helped women give birth,
it led to a higher death
rate among the mothers.
Semmelweis implemented
chlorine handwashing practices
throughout the hospital,
and death rates dropped significantly.
Now, there are a lot of
disease-causing germs out there.
Meet bacterial conjunctivitis,
or, as you may know it, pink eye:
the pus-producing, eye-burning infection.
Say you go to the bathroom
and don't wash up afterwards.
That bacteria makes its
way onto your hands,
and then a simple eye scratch will set
your pink eye into motion.
After preparing uncooked
meat, petting certain animals,
or coming in contact with fecal matter,
your stomach is about
to feel pretty terrible.
Diarrhea-causing illnesses,
like salmonella or giardiasis,
are 30% more likely when
you don't wash your hands.
And even after you recover,
you are likely to find yourself catching
these illnesses again and again.
As you continue touching
contaminated surfaces
and shaking hands, more
germs come into the mix.
You are 20% more likely to
catch respiratory viruses,
like influenzas, the common cold,
and, of course, COVID-19,
potentially leading to complications
or even severe pneumonia.
And then there's the norovirus.
This severe stomach virus only needs
a single particle to infect you.
Influenzas need 50 to 100.
So without handwashing,
you're almost guaranteed to
catch it sooner or later.
Now, you could diminish
your chances of getting
any of these diseases by
simply not touching your face.
But good luck;
one small study found that on average,
people touch their faces
over 20 times an hour.
And, sure, germs will die eventually
if they haven't been
transported to an opening,
but because you won't be
able to stop touching things,
you also won't be able
to stop picking up new
germs and other grime,
so your hands will get
dirtier and dirtier,
smellier and smellier.
And chances are you aren't
moisturizing either,
which means your hands will become dry
and cracks will form, creating
a perfect pocket for germs.
Let's say that now you
get a cut on your hand.
Not only will all those diseases
have an even easier way inside,
the most menacing germs might just join
this infection party.
Staphylococcus, more
commonly known as staph,
can be a relatively
harmless group of bacteria
and can even be commonly
found in some people's noses.
But when a wound opens
up and staph moves in,
expect skin irritations, boils, fevers,
and even blood infections.
Some strains of staph and other bacteria
take it one step further.
Welcome the flesh-eating bacteria,
also known for causing necrotizing
soft tissue infections.
This life-threatening
infection is a result
of bacteria invading the skin,
often when a cut or wound is present.
It can destroy the skin, muscle,
and, if untreated, lead to death.
So, you now have a cocktail
of infectious diseases,
severe blisters, rashes,
and your flesh is being eaten alive.
It's right about now you
might want to rush off
and wash your hands.
But remember, it's not
about how often you wash;
it's about how and when you wash.
For how, make sure it's
for at least 20 seconds,
covering every inch of your hand.
If you don't have a sink or clean water,
use at least 60% alcohol hand
sanitizer for 20 seconds,
making sure the hands stay wet throughout.
And for when, wash whenever you think
you might have come in contact with germs.
And try to see how long you can go
without touching your face.